we're back with a fox news alert an
agreement to restore the iran nuclear
deal expected within days russia there
to broker the deal as it attacks ukraine
today you're watching oil prices the
average price of regular gasoline topped
four dollars a gallon
and premium gas prices across the
country hit a new all-time high crude
oil is at its highest point in about a
decade this fueling republican backlash
of biden's energy policies the
administration's choices when he first
came into office put us in this tenuous
position with energy independence in the
united states instead of being an
exporter of energy we became a consumer
of russian oil this needs to stop this
notion that somehow banning russian oil
would raise prices on american consumers
is an admission that this guy that this
killer that this butcher vladimir putin
has leverage over us why would we want
that leverage to continue why would we
have someone like him to have the power
to raise gas prices on americans we have
weakened ourselves and it's because the
leftists their focus is on climate as
their religion what we have to do is say
common sense has to prevail in that we
are an energy-based economy
sean it's astonishing that president
biden hadn't stood up in front of the
american people and at least made the
case of why are they paying we're we're
this close to paying record high
gasoline prices in this country tomorrow
we'll probably hit a new record north of
4.11 cents a gallon and diesel prices
tomorrow are going to hit a new record
high that filters through inflation
because trucking and flying anything and
everything in this country to its
destination is going to cost more and
biden is nowhere to be found in
explaining this to the american people
so i'm going to explain it dig in
because oil however you guys say oil is
oil right so whether it comes from
venezuela or iran or russia um by the
way american oil is cleaner than russian
oil it begs the question why don't we
produce american oil it's american jobs
it's american security it's american
revenue to our federal coffers and i
think the answer is in the thought
leader of the democrat party which is
bernie sanders right bernie sanders
loved the communist venezuelans he loved
the old soviet union he signed on to the
iran deal so these are people who don't
believe in making america strong their
policies make america weak that if we go
even to the green new deal where do we
buy windmills from and solar panels and
batteries from not in america we buy
them from china and take another step
further degen they're they're trying to
teach our kids critical race to teach
our american kids how to hate their
history and hate their country so i am
really hard pressed to make an argument
how democrats love america and want
america to be strong because everything
they do is making this country weaker
and less secure less safe and we're
spending way more money as they
implement their policies
joey
sean mentioned venezuela u.s officials
have gone down to meet with the
venezuelan regime to discuss oil exports
that were cut off in beginning in 2019
by the trump administration russia in
the middle of the iran deal is once
guarantees that ukraine related
sanctions won't prevent it from trading
with tehran and you've got anthony
blinken now talking about the u.s is
weighing a russian oil ban
i do
i don't understand by the way u.s
refiners are already um cutting off
buying additional russian oil about a
third of russian oil of exports are
already off the market but i don't know
how any of this makes sense in terms of
this administration wants to continue to
buy oil from regimes that hate us
like
venezuela but won't
sign off on one new drilling permit here
in the u.s yeah well you can spit in my
face and tell me it's raining but
thankfully we have fox weather right so
there's a litmus test here on
information when jinsaki stands at the
podium and says that our gas prices are
going up because russia is invading
ukraine that is textbook gaslighting and
it tells you the administration is not
interested in an honest conversation
about this these things don't happen
overnight russia isn't the singular
reason why our gas and energy is going
through the roof just like meat packers
aren't why we have inflation in the
grocery store
but an administration willing to blame
meat packers for inflation on groceries
is very willing to blame russia for bad
energy policy all of these things are
things that have built up over the last
couple of years or several years and i
think that the nuance here is what gets
overlooked it's not about just more
drilling it's not about just a pipeline
it's about administration having a
posture towards energy that gets
american investors excited and allows us
to go tap the energy we have and that's
what we don't have
well there hasn't been one new onshore
federal
uh
lease
from the biden administration in his
time in office i i can talk i
the day this man took office i started
talking about they're going
taking a jackhammer to our energy sector
and it is american prosperity and also
gives us power over nations that hate us
so we ceded power and wealth to vladimir
putin by not
opening up the spigot if you will not by
by
releasing leases and drilling in this
country alicia and this is what's
happened
we don't have any way of fighting we
don't have any way of offsetting cutting
off vladimir putin and russian oil
exports because we're not drilling
enough in the united states
so what i can tell you is
after the keystone pipeline project was
cut off i went to nebraska and talked to
the workers who were down there but i
also talked to the governor pete
ricketts republican of nebraska who made
the point that first of all the demand
doesn't change right and if we're
talking about climate change and you're
worried about your carbon footprint a
produced barrel of oil is a produced
barrel of oil regardless of where that
happens there's going to be a carbon
footprint to the earth and so if you're
looking at let's say venezuela then
you're also talking about adding the
fossil fuels that it takes to get it
here because it has to then travel and
that's where his frustration came and i
think a lot of americans are
experiencing that as well i'll just
quote andy lipow alicia yeah what sean
is that joey or sean
one last point this is sean so i i think
we can also forget that the woke wall
street banks and hedge fund managers
that control a lot of american money now
because they're so woke don't want to
invest in oil and gas and so sometimes
the money flow to get these new wells
online isn't there they're all they've
all gone crazy woke
up and we
go ahead no i i was just going to add
one thing andy lippau who i rely on he's
in a great source for information on the
oil and gas business the u.s is
producing all it can right now to
increase production we have to drill
more wells if we want more oil in the
u.s we have to drill for it don't dial 1
800 opec opec plus that includes russia
and at about
seven months into the byte
administration they actually had the
audacity to ask opec to pump more oil
ask russia to pump more oil
that's that's the idiocy of this
administration alicia back to you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else